Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome
(silently) Why...?
Put it on.
Ethan: Oh.
Ok.
*Tyler burps into his arm*
Ethan: OHH Good song!
Mark: Anyway
Welcome to a very perverse game of truth.
telling-ness.
The cold.
Hard.
Truth.
This is the Truth or Wet Challenge
*lip smack* I hate that.
This is the Truth or Death Challenge
Either way
What's gonna happen is.
We've got Ethan here
And he can't.
He can't hear a word that were saying so..
He is completely ignorant to everything that we're gonna be doing to him.
And uh... he has no idea why he came over here today
He's sitting in that chair
And we're gonna play a kind of game of 2 truths and a lie. Basically,
I'm gonna quietly whisper into his mouth
EYES.
I'm gonna use my lips to shoot my information into his eyes.
He's gonna try to read my lips and not only does he have to determine what I said.
He has to judge whether what he
thinks I said was a truth.
Or a lie.
Makes sense?
If it doesn't you'll see real soon.
Are you ready?
Ethan: Good drums.
Ready?
Mark: Yeah.
Ethan: Yeah.
Mark: Ready?
Ethan: I guess so.
Mark: Ok.
Ethan: Don't have a choice
Mark: Alright. Are you ready?
Ethan: Am I ready?
You bet
I'm not.
But I'll do it.
Mark: Okay cool. Do you know what's happening here?
Ethan: Okay? Cool, so do you know what's happening here?
Mark: Nice.
Ethan: Yes.
Mark: Nope
*Kathryn and Amy giggle*
Ethan: Nope
Mark: Okay.
He's got double layer protection. Not only does he have music blasting, but we've got
industrial-strength earmuffs here that are meant for construction sites with loud operating machinery
so I'm gonna come up with the truth or a lie, and he's gonna judge it as such.
*Mark whispers* I grew up in a small town called Milford
Ethan: I get three tries right?
Mark: Umhmm...
Ethan: Okay.
One more time a little bit slower
*Mark repeats himself* I grew up in a small town called Milford.
Ethan: Ah! I grew up in a small town called Milford.
Ethan: Aah!
Wait!
That's what you said!
Isn't it?
Mark: *whispers* And?
Ethan: Wait you can go again.
You don't have to do that yet.
I grew up in a small town called
Milford.
That's all you SAID!!!
WHY!!!!
*Tyler dumps the ice water on Ethan*
Aah!That's so cold!
OOoooohhhh My ASS!
It's going in my ass!
Mark: Was it a truth or was it a lie?
Ethan: OH!
*Ethan and Tyler laugh* Mark: You idiot!
*Ethan and Tyler continue laughing*
*Facepalm*
Mark: You deserve that one.
*Ethan laughs*
So he's gonna be in that hot seat
Ethan: COMPLETELY forgot!
Mark: Yeah! *Tyler starts laughing again*
Wow!
Ethan: Is that true?
Mark: Yes.
Ethan: I just know that's a place in Ohio.
Mark: Yeah.
So uh...
The point of this is.
Once he's able to NOT get ice dunked on him
We rotate out who's sitting in that chair.
And you would have had that!
Ethan: I would have immediately!
Mark: Yeah! you would've!
Ethan: Shit!
Mark: Yeah! Alright put it back on.
Ethan: This is the worst!
Mark: And he has to keep getting dunked until he gets it right so until that happens
Who knows?
All right, so now that Ethan was an idiot
He has to stay in that seat
But Tyler and I would get to switch and now Tyler's at risk of being in that seat next so-
Tyler: Are you ready?
Ethan: Am I ready?
Yyyeah-
Tyler: I won a state title playing water polo
Ethan: Uhhh
I think he said something about water polo go again Tyler: I won a state title playing water polo.
Ethan: I think he said, Oooh wait... a minute
Sir *Ethan giggles*
I think you said "I won a state's in water polo" or
something along those lines.
Which I believe to be true?
*Terrified and painful screams produced from Ethan* AAAh NoooO
Mark: I'll give it to him. *Mark Laughs*
Ethan: I'm good?
Tyler: Yeah. *Mark Laughing*
Mark: Are you ready?
Tyler: *shouting* I can't hear a word you're saying but I am ready.
Ethan: he's VERY loud
Tyler: *still shouting*  aAh thats cold ass, I got ass ice, ice on my ass
Tyler:  I'm terrified
How loud am I?
Mark: Very.
He knows so much about me, I gotta be very careful about this one.
I worked summer vacations in school,
working as a carpenter
Tyler: I worked during the summer as a carpenter.
That would be true
Mark: *mumbling sadly* That's true.
Ethan: fuck
Ethan: That's okay, okay Mr. Man time to get your medicine
Okay, Ready? *Claps to get Mark's attention*
Ready? When I was young I had a lizard named Cody Mark: That was like,
that was like a paragraph. Tyler: That's what yours was like! You can't hear me. Ethan: when I was young
I had a lizard named Cody. Mark: Ahhhh
Mark: When I was ten
I had
Uh-
Uh, AAHHhh, UUUhhhhhh
Mark: Llliiight house on Tooonggaa...False.
Ethan: Incorrect
Mark: NOooOooOOo Ethan: Incorrect
Mark: Gah! Oooohhh *General noises of cold displeasure*
Ethan: Good. Very good, very good.
Do you want to know what I said?
Mark: NO!
Ethan: Okay *giggles*
Mark: What did he say?
Tyler: In college I played lacrosse
In college, I played lacrosse
Mark: *loudly* In art school, I played lacrosse?
False?!
Tyler: Dang it!
Mark: Why what is the gutter? Tyler: I think it's good. Mark: Did I get it? Ethan: I think well I think judges. Mark: JUDGES?
Mark: I GOT A THUMBS UP Tyler: You're clear. Mark: YEAH!
Tyler: Ya know what I actually said? Mark: What was it? Tyler: In college I played lacrosse Mark: OOOOHhhH
Tyler: So you were really close but you just said "art school." Mark: I was like, "I didn't think you went through art school. *All laugh*
Tyler: Hold on I can still hear you because I got a tighten it cuz his head's big
Mark: what? fuck you.
Tyler: I HAVE A SMALL HEAD! Mark: FUUUCK YOU! Tyler: I know what you're saying. Mark: FuuUcK yoU.
Ethan: In 2010 I was the level 8 regional champion. Tyler: THAT'S LIKE A MILE LONG, WHAT IS THIS?
Ethan: In 2010 I was the level 8
regional champion.
Tyler: In school I was never a good student?
Ethan: Not even close!
Tyler: *screams in high pitched, girly AHHHs*
Ethan: It's not that cold. Tyler: All right talking like this. Mark: In high school
I took AP Chemistry. Tyler: IN HIGH SCHOOL I TOOK AP CHEMISTRY?
false.
Mark: No, no he's right, I didn't take AP Chemistry *Ethan flails angrily*
God damn it. You know too much about me. Ethan: Did you take honors chemistry? Mark: No I didn't take- I took AP physics
Not AP chemistry god dammit. I'm in there. Ethan: Alright. Ready big boy?
Ready? As a senior I
didn't take a math or a science. Mark: Why does you--? Why does he have a long?
This asshole here! Ethan: As a senior I
Didn't take a math or a science
Mark: *loudly* In
Something school, I didn't take math or science- True? Ethan: true. Mark: Ha HA
ha
uncuff yourself. Mark: Fuuck you
Tyler: In college I mastered in sports administration. Ethan: In college I mastered in sports and education- no sports administration
In college I mastered in sports administration. That's true. Tyler: dammit
Ethan: ha ha, Rekt 'em *all giggle* Tyler: You just said 'Rectum" Ethan: I know. Mark, mockingly: Guys, guys did you just hear that? He said RECTUM.
*All Laughing*
I Didn't lose my virginity until I was 20 years old.
Tyler: I didn't lose my virginity until I was 24. That's false.
*Ethan stands up, prepared to dump Tyler*
That wa- *Mark shakes head*
*In background* Nope
Nope. Yeah
*Mark giggles*
Tyler: *Screams, yet again.*
Mark: No, that was a no
Tyler: Oh
Mark: Because I said 20 years old. Tyler: OH, I thought you said 24. Darn it.
Mark: You Would've been, like, totally fine if you got it right!
Tyler: I know
Mark: *Sighs* I'm sorry, yeah.
After you get it once it's not as cold the second time
Mark: Well, don't tell them that.
Tyler: Once you get it once-
Mark: No, DON'T
*Mark and Ethan laugh*
Tyler: It's not as cold the second time.
Mark and Ethan: *Continues to laugh*
Ethan: Here's a short one
I have had four dogs
Tyler: I have had four something
Ethan: I have had four dogs.
Tyler: I have had four dogs?- True
Tyler: Is it three?
Ethan: It's three.
Tyler: DANG IT!
Tyler: *scream*
Mark: *giggles*
Tyler: *Screams again, and Mark laughs again*
There's an ice cube..
On my anus.
*Ethan and Mark giggle*
Mark: True!
*Mark and Ethan laugh*
Tyler: Right on the butthole
Mark: Well move it!
Mark: So, uh..
Because I like to change the rules on the fly we're gonna start dumping on the head now
Originally we were gonna protect it so the headphones don't get, you know hit, but I think it's
Mark: *Quietly* Worth it. *Normal voice* It's well protected. Those headphones are good. Right?
Tyler: *Confused* Uh..
Mark:  *Gives thumbs up*
Tyler: *Nods*
*Ethan and Mark giggle*
Ethan: So he's- He agrees!
Mark: We first met in third grade.
*Ethan laughing*
Tyler: I read something about your ass
*Mark and Ethan giggle*
Mark: We first met in third grade.
Tyler: This isn't a fair question.
Mark: It's a completely fair question.
Tyler: We first met in third grade
You say it's fourth. I say it's third
Mark: *aggressively* I wasn't in Milford in
third grade!
Tyler: I'm saying- I'm saying false.
Mark: *Still shouting* I- You're a LIAR and you're gonna burn for your lies
*Mark laughs*
*Ethan laughs with Mark at Tyler's suffering*
Tyler: I have a shoulder cramp, holy crap
Mark: Oh no, you okay?
Tyler: Yeah, it just hurts like hell right now
Mark: That is totally an unfair one so if you want to get a free dump on me you' can go ahead and do that
I'll allow it.
Tyler: Can I recover first? I need a massage.
Mark: *Laughs* You should see it after I said that, like.
Mark: Everyone backstage was like, "Oh, shit!"
Tyler: I said that was an unfair question because I say it was third grade
and he said it was fourth grade, but because it's you it's false
Mark: *realizes* Ohh
Oh, so you did get it
*Mark Laughs*
Mark: OOPS!
All right, uh, I
I got caught up in the heat of the moment
uh because I got him, but then I didn't got him
Uh
So he gets a free dump on me
Mark: Ah! Ooo, EHH, OOO, EUUGH!
Mark: *Pants*
Ethan: Okay, here you go now it's the real time.
Mark: Oh boy. Let me
Mark: Dry off my hands first.
Ethan: We don't have towels.
Mark: Okay. That's fine. I got some dry patches around my ankles
I need to think of something that will make Mark look bad
That he doesn't know about me.
What does Mark- Whats a- what's a fact that Mark should know about me...
Tyler:*whispering* Birth date would be pretty good *unintelligble*
Ethan No he knows my birthday
Amy *offscreen*: Does he?
Tyler: Um no, probably not the exact date
He's so bad at remembering that
He doesn't even remember mine, Ethan
*Claps to get Mark's attention*
Ethan: My birthday is October 25th
Mark: People think something-something is covered in filth
*Ethan giggles*
Mark: Alright, go again
Ethan: My birthday is October 25th
Mark: People think
That
No, that's it. No, don't you lie to me- people think that Carmageddon was made by Dan and Phil
But go ahead. NO HeY WHOA HEY I get another one- My brother was buried in an avalanche
Dan and Phil
Fuck you
Ethan: Okay okay here you-
Tyler: You have one more try
Mark:Ahuh
Ethan: You have one more try keep, keep it [the headphones] off
Tyler:But, I get to fill this up completely and dump it on you if you get it wrong
Mark *Stuttering*: Wha- What Why? No! I don't agree to that I'll just take what's there now!
Why would-
Ethan: Nope we're doing it anyway. You don't get to make the shots
Ready?
Mark:No
Ethan: You have to answer true or false my birthday is October
25th
true or false
Mark: Bob's...
*Ethan laughing*
Ethan: Not Bob
Mark: No no no I'm figuring this out
Wait,
Ethan: so you don't
Mark: Wait, hey, shut up shut up shut up shut up. Shut up you
Mark: Bob's is.. someday...
*Ethan laughs some more*
Mark: I think it's the 21st.
And yours is aft- no is it the 19th? 18th? It's some day
in that range *Both laugh*
Yours... 26??
5th?
Ethan:That wasn't the question
Ah, he returns
All right, Imma ask you one final time. My birthday is October 25th-- true or false
*Kerchoo*
Mark: Imma say false
Ethan: Ahhh, Correct.
Mark: YAYYY!
Ethan: Do you know what day it is?
Mark: It's the 24th right?
Ethan: Yeah, 24th
Mark: Ahh fft, fuck you guys!! Fuck all of you! Fuck ALL of you!
Ethan: My point still stands
Mark *Mockingly*: The whole time 'OH BAD FRIEND' KANYE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
Ethan: I KNOW YOUR BIRTHDAY
Mark *suddenly calm*: When is it?
Tyler: You guys both know mine?
Mark: January....
Ethan: *Contemplative fish/sucking noises, and popping noises*
Tyler: If you get this wrong I'm dumping it on both of you.
Ethan: Well that's not fair
Amy *offscreen*: KATHRYN JUST SAID IT OUT LOUD
Tyler: That's why!
Mark: Wha- what what?
Tyler: Don't say it again
Ethan: Oh, we were- we were concen-
Mark: Is it the 20th?
Tyler: No
Mark: It's the 21st
Mark: 22nd?
Tyler: No
Ethan: 18th
*taking random guesses now* Ethan: 15th?
Tyler: No
Mark: 32nd?
Ethan: 13TH?
*Tyler laughs*
Mark: 24?
Ethan: no.
Tyler: Get on the floor!
Mark: 5th. 5th?
Ethan: Get on the floor? That wasn't part of the deal!?
Mark: That wasn't part of the deal! 6?
Tyler: Get!
Mark: 9th?
Ethan: No!
Tyler: Then side-by-side in the chairs
Ethan: That wasn't the dealio!
Mark: 26- 25th... 24th
Tyler: Sit in the chairs- wait, what did you just say?
Mark: 25th?
Tyler: Sit down, you're still getting dunked.
Ethan: OH It IS the 25th!
Tyler: It's exactly one month from Christmas. I say that all the time
Sit down
Mark: Oooooohhhh. I just shut that out
Ethan: Well Why is this fair?
Tyler: Sit down! Neither one got it right.
Ethan: I think that this isn't okay
Mark: You know I didn't think it was either, but here we are at this juncture
Ethan: OH NO OH No Oh No!
Mark: And now I-
*Mark yelps*
Mark: Ennnnghhhrhhh, Auh!
Ethan: My feet! My feet
Nn-- *Mark panting*
Ethan: IIIIMM in pain! I'm in pain!
Tyler: And that's why you remember your friends' birthdays
Ethan: Who's turn is it?
Kathryn *offscreen*: Yours
Mark: Yours. Get in the chair
Ethan: I'm having a hard time walking
Mark: aaAAHH
So we've got one last question for you. Did we
celebrate your birthday?
Ethan: Did we?
celebrate my birthday? as a group together? this year like for my 21st?
Uhhhhh. I mean no. Not...
Mark: *Sniffs* AAooohhhhhh
Well.
Ethan: What do you mean?
Mark: Come with us.
Ethan: I can't walk
Amy *offscreen*: We're gonna bring it, we're gonna bring it.
Mark: Oh, we're gonna bring it. All right you stay right there. You stay right there.
Ethan: I'm sooo afraid
Tyler: Make sure that covers your eyes
Mark: Cover that *puts earmuffs on Ethan*
Ethan: Dude I'm so- OH NO! I'm in a sensory deprivation chamber!
Please don't hurt me please. Plea--I'm really
Please don't hurt- I'm really afraid can I take these off?
Mark: No you leave it.
Ethan: I'm really afraid
I'm really afraid
Mark: All right, it's time
Amy *offscreen*: No it's not!
Mark: No, don't take anything off yet
Amy *offscreen*: It's not time
Mark: It's not time
Ethan: I have to pee
Oh! It's a balloon!
*Balloons squeak*
Ethan: Hey!
Kathryn:We gotta take these off of him
Amy: No one spoil it!
Ethan: Uh, Hello?
It's a birthday hat are we gonna celebrate? But I feel like my celebration will cause me pain.
Mark: We could just be nice friends
Ethan: I doubt it.
*Mark and Ethan laugh*
Amy: You ready to lift off?
Mark: You ready?
Ethan: Lift off?? I don't-
Mark: You ready to lift off? Amy: Your dooders!
Ethan: Sure
Mark: Uncover!
Mark: HAPPY BIRTHDAAAYYYYYYY
Ethan: Awwww
Amy: Yayy!!!!
Ethan: I thought it was gonna be painful! It wasn't painful!
Tyler: Don't hit me please
Ethan: Okay
Where should I hit him?
Tyler *mumbles*: The lower the better for my safety
Amy: I think right in the gut!
Tyler: Yeah
Ethan: Right in the gut?
Kathryn: Yeah!
Ethan: Ok ready?
Mark: No
Ethan: I'm gonna give him a good whomp
Tyler: Just don't hit me!
*Thwack*
Ethan: Oooh That's rock solid!!
Tyler: Ow it's twisting around in my hand.
Ethan: It's really rock solid.
Amy: Oh are you okay Tyler?
Tyler: I'm good!
*THWACK*
Tyler: Ow! It twists!
Mark *to Ethan*: You're a real wimp, you know that?
Ethan:NO!
...a good knee
*THWACK*
nope...
Oh almost! *Everyone laughs*
Amy: Keep goin'!
*THWACK*
THWACK!
Ethan *while laughing*: FILLED WITH HOT DOGS???
*Everyone laughing*
Ethan: DROP HIM!
*Multiple thwacks as Ethan hits the pinata*
Tyler: decapitated his body!
Ethan *laughing*: Its filled, with hot dogs???
Kathryn: And ketchup!
*Everyone laughing*
Mark: Happy birthda-- Ah, that smells really bad *starts laughing*
Ethan: Ahhh thanks guys!!!
Mark: You're welcome!
Tyler: Ah that smells so bad.
Mark: Now clean this shit up!
Ethan: Am I required to eat all this?? *laughs*
Mark: Yes!
Tyler: Dive in! No hands allowed!
All right, so this has been the Truth or Death Challenge, this has been the Truth
or Wet Challenge, this has been the Cold Hard Truth Challenge, this has been
a horrible experience
If there's anything that I'm gonna associate with Ethan's birthday from now on it's that is pain.
Ethan: CLOWNS FILLED WITH HOT DOGS
*All laugh*
So anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching this was a lot of fun. Happy birthday Ethan
thank you to Amy and Kathryn for coming up with this whole deal and
Thank you Tyler for forgiving me for not remembering his birth. So thanks again and as always
We will see you in the next video buh-bye
All: Bye!!!